Owen Benjamin you are you work some time
in Hollywood now you ask your script
writer for the louder from Crowder show
formally front good friends with Joe
Rogan and you actually wrote the song
for Tommy Ron Robinson yeah yeah I had
always thought that you guys hated Jesus
Muslims reading the Koran strapping
bombs to themselves and running into a
concert to kill white people I can't
believe I fell for that lie bismillah
alhamdulillah assalamualaikum greenies a
peace peace be unto you welcome to the d
sharma dear host now a few weeks back we
did a program a reaction video because
we heard that a gentleman by the name of
Owen Benjamin had some very nice things
to say about Islam and Muslims
now who's Owen Benjamin Owen Benjamin
was a scriptwriter for louder for
Crowder worked in Hollywood also was
friends with Joe Rogan has been on the
Joe Rogan podcast he also wrote the song
for one of the leading islamaphobe slum
haters in the world for Tommy Robins
Robins so you can imagine who he was
rolling with and the kind of things he
used to say so when we heard that he had
some very nice things to say we had some
nice thing to say back to him so we did
this video for him we sent him some love
he says some love back now guess who is
with us here on this episode of the Dee
show that's right no other then Owen
Benjamin that's right here on the Dean
show coming up mister everybody
[Applause]
hello what's up brother how are ya
how you doing oh and how you been how
you doing good man thanks for having me
I'm excited thanks for accepting the
call of course of course nice background
there oh yeah my garden I was just every
time I open I just uh I just burn the
wrappers just so it doesn't accumulate
so we got some some sheep some goats no
way dude that's awesome man
yeah I'm really I just had some ghost
milk this morning what kind of goats
no I the the goats my goats we don't I
don't have no goats right now right now
I have sheep and as far as the goat's
milk from I don't know if you've heard
of family farms
I haven't now so okay you know it's
ironic and we might just we just get
into it it's ironic that coca-cola and
Pepsi and you know drinking one of these
a day can increase your chances of
diabetes by they say 30 percent but it
real milk raw milk is illegal how about
that it's crazy isn't that that's not
why the only way to do it is just do it
yourself yeah so what happens is they
have the co-ops so they have these coops
family farm is the coop and then they
bring the milk to the church so they
have this church here you go there you
sign up and then every two weeks they
bring the milk so you can order raw
cow's milk or goat's milk but I've never
myself milked the goats that we've had
I've never done that but I but I was
listening I went to Tractor Supply Store
after I heard you speaking about
something about how you can actually get
you're referring to people being
distracted but the goats when you want
to milk them you have their you know
their heads and what does that called I
don't know I don't know what it's called
but the whole the the metaphor is so
applicable on society where the goat is
eating from the little tray from the
little treats and then you just put this
iron thing over their neck and they
don't even notice and then you're just
in the back milking them and I was I was
looking at it I'm like that reminds me
of a
popcorn like when people are just at the
movies and they're getting their soul
milked almost without the the fear
propaganda and the trauma-based mind
control watching these movies and these
television shows where you know there's
people that are now controlling others
minds and dreams and perceptions as they
just eat from a tub of corn and I was
looking at this goat and I'm like imma
go and I'm like whose milk and me did
you make your own contraption or you
bought it my neighbor made it for me
he's up he's going metal yeah he's got a
blowtorch on that stuff
oh okay alright so yes I'm really into
eating real food avoiding fake food you
know because to the way the key to good
health is eating the the food that human
beings been intended to eat and that's
the food that the Creator has given us
not the processed junk garbage fake
foods because exactly man and it's the
goat it's interesting you said that
about goat milk because goat milk is is
objectively healthier for human beings
than cow milk yeah uh it's it doesn't
trigger lactose intolerance in people
and it also has the the good the good
bacteria in it that helps especially
children develop strong immune systems
yeah so I'm really into I would never
drink any of the conventional you know
the FDA it's it's ironic the FDA Food
and Drug Administration they have as the
number one allergenic food is actually
milk so I was thinking how could this
milk that the Creator has given us how
can this be causing people to get sick
but it's not the real milk it's not fake
factorise homogenized a fake fake milk
yeah it's the same with corn you know
it's like what we have all this
genetically modified hyper high fructose
corn syrup stuff like we have we grow
non-gmo corn and it's delicious and it's
healthy and it's great and it's the old
corn like corn used to be smaller
carrots used to be purple you know it's
like a lot of this food is just it's
it's almost like how Satan mimics you
know it's a mimicry it's a it's a
mockery of the creator's food as you sow
alcohol
you put it and a lot of the FDA man a
lot of those guys are like Rosa
Rosicrucians and weirdos they they're
all about poisons and potions and stuff
you know 80% I heard 80% of the corn is
GMO oh it's terrible
yeah but old-school maize is uh is not
as healthy you know it's from the
Creator as you put it and uh and that's
and that's I just read something today
that citric acid is from black mold I
used to think it was from oranges you
know I got when you read in the label
that citric acid they extract that out
of mold you know it's getting very very
intense out there guys we are just
jumping right into it I'm with Owen
Benjamin and the conversation is flowing
I just we just jump right into it yeah
thank you so much for being with us here
on the Dean show I really appreciate it
just to kind of give a little bit of a
breakdown please correct me if I'm ever
wrong Owen Benjamin you were you work
some time in Hollywood yeah you were you
a script writer for the louder from
Crowder show formerly front good friends
with Joe Rogan and you actually wrote
the song for Tommy wrong Robinson yeah
yeah bro me and the Bears child to the
Bears but uh you know it was it was a
group effort and we wanted to just get
people um you know I saw a man that I
thought was speaking honestly to the
problems in England and so we always
support that and then you know uh it was
revealed that you know he wasn't quite
being as honest as I once thought but
you know whatever it's all good he's not
very tall you touched a lot of hearts
you touched a lot of Muslims hearts
brother
and when I say Muslim look by definition
because we say so I just want to define
these words because if I say Muslims
someone thinks oh that's the guys from
never forget 9/11 that's the guys who
you know who are about to blow us up the
boogeyman coming to get you but Owen
when we say Muslim Muslim if you if you
define the word it simply means one male
or female who has chosen to acquire
peace by submitting to the owner of
peace the creator to have his nerve so
when I say Muslim I want to remove that
from anyone's mind that's that's that's
listening so when you said you said
main thing is in one of your talks you
said my main thing here is to help so
many people who hate Muslims who are
withstanding evil these beautiful people
my main thing is to help people not hate
so many good-hearted Muslims that are
wit withstanding evil and they are the
type of people you you want to root for
these scholarly beautiful Muslim people
don't let the media paint you know a
fifth of the planet is people that
deserve to be bombed as a sacrifice so
you we want we want to help with that we
want to help because there's a lot a lot
of hate out there and we'll go ahead
yeah there's a lot of programming that
I've realized has happened in America of
the anti-muslim programming because we
all know there's Pharisees in every
religion there's some bad Muslims and
bad Christians and bad community but
that whole um you know just the
boogeyman that you're referring to I
over the course of my life as I've
cleaned out my life you know I stopped
drinking not that I had a drinking
problem and I just I wasn't gonna do the
wizardry on myself like it's just five
beers to relax the more I just got sin
away from me the more I could see
clearly and the way I judge people is
let your yes mean yes what you know me
know is very important to me and I
started realizing that I had more in
common with some of these muslims that i
did a lot of these converts christians
christian and name only and other
they're blaspheming they're saying eve
was transgender and you know all this
insane stuff have a rainbow flag in
front you know promoting sodomy and
stuff and I'm like well that Muslim
family is just having a bunch of kids
and they seem like they are very honest
people I'm like what is going on because
I used to think that Muslims were the
boogeyman and there are some that are
Muslim and ain't named only as we all
know but it's not something that really
changed my perspective was when a Muslim
friend of mine I heard him say Jesus
peace be upon him and I had always
thought that you guys hated Jesus you
know and that was and that blew my mind
because I listened to Ben Shapiro I'm
Joe Rogan talked about how Jesus Christ
was a common criminal and was killed for
against Rome which is just insane tamed
statement and then my Muslim friend
would say Jesus peace be upon him and I
was like huh
that kind of made it through the
programming and to me it isn't this big
theological thing it's like how you and
I before we started the show in the
beginning we're just talking about goat
milk and what's in food and and that is
what we're facing in the future is uh
you know guys like me and you are trying
to eat healthy we're trying to have
families are trying to honor our Creator
and we have more in common than I do
with a lot of these materialists it
seemed only out of themselves and they
uh they speak lies and they are selfish
and they they've they've almost like
accepted this this world of self
gratification and sin you know it's
almost like the lowercase I before every
Apple product it's it's narcissism with
no but you're still lowercase you know
yeah and oh that's changed my mind
about Muslims and I think another thing
that people don't realize is it's not
like a race you know like when someone
says Muslim it's not um a lot of times
people think Arabs and they think a
specific group of Arabs and then and
that's just not true at all and so
that's where I'm at today
yeah the population if you look at how
many Muslims from around the world you
know you got more Muslims in Indonesia
or Malaysia you know again a Muslim
could be polish Italian American I was
born here my parents are from the
Balkans from Europe so it's it's not
like many people had that stereotyped
almost some other Arab you know well
yeah and all the false the moon-landing
really got me going on I'm the ability
of people to lie because I think a lot
of people can't fathom the scope of some
of these lies that that kept us in these
thirty-year wars with people that we
have no business being over there and
something like the ariana grande concert
like now that I realized that it's not
just Muslims reading the Koran strapping
bombs to themselves and running into a
concert to kill white people I can't
believe I fell for that lie you know
it's it's it's
these traumatic events are made so that
the local populations will continue with
these Wars you know in the wars they
benefit no one except for the people
that are profiting from the war sums
like building sandcastles with the with
the tides you know it's only benefiting
the people in the Sandcastle Union you
know and so much American life so much
life in the Middle East is just
unnecessarily sacrificed at the altar of
greed and I just you know I just think
it's it's pretty wild just to grow and
see and I think becoming a father you
really your instincts kick in with other
men where you see another man and you're
like is that a threat to my family and
so many you know devout Muslims Muslims
that honor the Creator the God of truth
the God are not a threat to my family
and I feel it instinctively and then
I'll see someone who is a liar and
someone who's a materialist and I'm like
that person is not allowed my home talk
to us about Santa Claus you talk about
you mentioned said you mentioned that
was one of the rabbit holes I think it's
pre-programming for for government
spying agencies it's like he sees you
when you're sleeping he knows when
you're awake it's like dude I don't want
to be watched by this fat man in the red
suit you know uh-huh Wow yeah so you you
you you mentioned the arguments that are
against Islam and I'm gonna again I'm
just for the audience I'm gonna define
Islam Muslim one who acquires peace by
submitting to the owner peace the
Creator Islam is the action of acquiring
peace by submitting your will to the
crater so you mentioned that the
arguments of Islam are starting to
become so absurd of fantasy you know and
Bret Hart and and CNN Fox News they
convenient they don't tell you that
actually Jesus is mentioned in the Quran
25 times you know actually his there's a
whole chapter you didn't you're named
after his Blessed Mother these things
they conveniently they don't mention
that you have to say peace be upon him
like you
this caught your attention when we say
Jesus peace be upon him they don't
mention these things but you know
suddenly that you know it's against
having relations outside of marriage you
know the these porn
interests usery all these things right
but when it comes down to the other
things like of Jesus or anything the
commonalities they don't mention they
never mention the commonalities and they
also I have a lot of respect as the
church I'm looking at in my area that's
done the best against the convergence is
the Orthodox Church they seem to still
be against usury sodomy they're Pro
monogamy Pro big family stuff like that
they a lot of people aren't mentioning
that a lot of Islamic areas have never
allowed in pornography that they've
never allowed in usury and you know I
think that our enemy is we have a common
enemy with with the Muslims and that is
the materialist and I think people can
get very wrapped up and the difference
is you know people get wrapped up in
Christianity the difference between
Catholic and Protestant and all this
stuff and they can endlessly bicker and
it's like well we're on the same page
that God has truths God His love got his
life with God created us we should give
gratitude to God and life is good you
know how it's like truth is good and
then from there we can build and I think
that we have so much we have a common
enemy in that that um and they don't
tell you that about Muslims you know
Muslims I always thought based on what
I've seen in the media as they just want
nothing more than just to blow up a
bunch of innocent people I thought it
was a death cult yeah and um and it's
not you know I there's there's people
that call themselves Muslims that are in
a death cult there's people that call
themselves Christians that are in a
death cult you know it's it's who is
your master
and so and I also really like the
economics economic knowledge of a lot of
Muslims you know I was listening it's
one I don't know what they're called the
leader sorry for my ignorance but uh
Widdecombe the leader of the Muslim
oh ma square they call me mom you have
my share of Imam yeah someone a leader
in the community an imam probably he was
breaking down inflation better than any
anybody I ever saw he was like you have
a camel he's like here's your camel is
now worth a donkey he's like he just
kept going and I was like yes I think
Islam has a really good grasp on the
economics of debt and how for you guys
it's so it's ingrained in your religion
that um you know debt goes against Allah
and so don't do it and and I think that
what we're facing now you know good
friend of mine box day broke down what
causes war cause people used to say
religion cause war and it's he broke
down that 97% of wars caused by debt and
so when you have these banking wars of
debt uh that's really what's spitting in
the face of our Creator not our
theological differences it's it's more
debt it's more you know every US dollar
has thirteen dollars of debt attached to
it and you go into all these churches
and I'm Christian I've know I'm but I do
have a problem with these converged
churches that's one reason why I was I I
just see a lot of Muslim families
worshiping better than a lot of
Christian families and that's not a
knock in Christianity that's just saying
why won't these Christians be Christian
like why won't they pray every day why
won't they um you know ask God for more
children and thank God when they have
more children how can someone beyond
like give their woman hormones to
sterilize their womb you know it's just
very shocking to me and so are the
values of Muslims I've grown to respect
as men leaders of their family and
outside of that I don't like getting in
theological fights I don't like the
endless arguments about it almost
reminds me of like Dungeons & Dragons
for people are like well how many hit
points do you have and I'm like do you
have gratitude towards the Creator
do you believe in truth you know are you
will you toil in the fields for you know
for your family and that's and that's
why
my opinion on Muslims it's changed over
the years
for for us and why we started the
program is specifically me as American
born here
background European in Bosnia you've
heard of Bosnia of course yeah and just
to to be a voice somewhat for for those
who are sincere genuine and they want to
they want to learn they want to know and
just to share just to share the
information to try to clear up much of
this muck that's out there and I'll give
you an example like there was this
pastor I was given a talk in in Colorado
and afterward this was a Juma Juma hood
by every Friday people will congregate
and then there was a pastor there he
approached I don't know he's a pastor
until he introduced himself he came up
he had visited before he introduced
himself he was elderly man named David
he was about probably in his late
sixties early seventies very nice man he
came up and he introduced himself and we
spoke and we sat down and we talked and
a few of us you know got together and
and I and then I I was out answering his
questions he had questions and we were
just having a nice dialogue talking and
then he said man I was I said how do you
how do you feel being in here like now
how do you feel how do you feel knowing
that you're not in a bomb-making factory
now right and I said I feel good I feel
I feel you know I feel good I said how
did you feel the first time you came in
he said he was like he was scared to
death so I couldn't so what when I heard
that I said this fear is real people
become victims to the fear and hate
machine so that's why I commend you when
you when when when you said I really you
know you you want to help people to stop
with this hate and that's due to the
ignorance so this man he didn't knows
but so naturally now you're gonna do
things out of not knowing out of
ignorance and now that fear it's a
repetitive cycle you know fear ignorance
and the hate and the violence and it
just never ending then the wars yeah and
the fear is from the devil it's like
it's it's his best tool you know just
just that that fear that that terror you
know and it open my eyes was finding out
how many of these terrorists being
arrested blah blah blah where people uh
that they've manipulated like
I'm had like autism and they'd like try
and get him to make a bomb and they were
really trying to mmm and it was it
remind me a lot of the war on drugs
where it'd be like these undercover
agents would try and make their quotas
and they'd go in and try and get someone
to didn't have any friends it might be a
little on the spectrum and then they
they rise to be like oh look we got
another one and it's like it's
fascinating to me to see that to just
see how much we were manipulated and how
much we shouldn't be continuing these
wars that just are leading to the debt
of America because you know to end the
fear to end the hate will help all
Americans because 22 trillion in debt
because we're in a land that we don't
need to be in you know if we're not what
this is another thing is the wars never
end unless people count eyes so what do
you do you kill a bunch of people you
don't have children you don't open up
shops you don't bring churches then they
just come back except they're just more
hardcore than before and it's just an
endless nonsense waste of life and you
know I remember when I was young my
brother had a couple Saudi Arabian
friends that he met when he went to
school in England and they came to visit
us he was fond Abdul and they were
Muslim and they were very very nice and
when I was a little kid I whoa cloth I
remember I just had this one cloth but I
just gave it to one of them is uh ah I
was like oh this could be a prayer rug
he was like oh thank you that's so cool
and then I forgot about those guys as
the media machine cranked up the hate
and the rage and the fear and stuff and
now looking back there were some of the
nicest people I knew you know and and
it's like and okay for example this show
like I told a couple people I was doing
this and some people like o Muslims o
and I'm like dude I did Joe Rogan three
times he's a freaking Satanist you know
it's like where were all these people
when I did Joe Rogan I'm like he
believes in Satan I'm like Muslims say
Jesus peace be upon him
you know they believe in the same God
and they're like oh yeah well you know
they added prophets well I'm like so
Mormons where's your rage against
Mormons and they're like well I'm
yeah because you weren't trained to hate
Mormons and I'm like get in control of
your own life your own brain I'm saying
so you mentioned training so you think
that that's that's a deliberate training
of the mass manipulation where you talk
about now being enslaved now people not
enslaved because it is fear and given up
there now not only money for point how
much four point five five trillion
dollars and all these senseless Wars and
then just given up your civil liberties
and whatnot yeah yeah no it's it hurts
the person you know the people to think
I'm crazy for saying Muhammad peace be
upon him at first I was doing it just to
piss off baby boomers but now I've
started to really be like it just feels
better to say peace be upon people that
others respect like if Muslims can say
Jesus peace be upon them why can't you
say peace be upon who they respect it's
just like an act of you know it's just
offering someone tea or taking your
shoes off at the door it doesn't cost
you anything to just show respect if
someone's being a nice man and then the
the rage and I'm like that rage you
might as well have the gun pointing at
you every bullet you shoot because you
know these people are capitalizing on
your hate your unjust hatred for human
beings you know it's one thing if you're
against the flooding of you know the
open borders you don't want your
community to go from Christian and
Muslim or something like that that's
fine but if you are against just them
doing what they're doing and you feel
you have the right to go there and bomb
their their wedding it's like you're a
ghoul and I uh and and I'm glad I know
this now say what one thing I'm
fortunate to have is I don't feel shame
when I learn something new some people
they have this trigger where if they
were wrong about something they won't
admit it because they don't want to look
stupid yeah and I don't have that I just
don't I'm like yeah I've learned that
Islam is not as far away from
Christianity as I once thought it was
Talmudic Judaism is way farther you know
and these are the people that I would
see I would see you know steven crowder
ben shapiro on a show meanwhile he's
given me grief for questioning the moon
landing and I'm like buddy that guy
thinks Jesus Christ was a criminal and
it's like this isn't making logical
sense to me and so I'm glad I've thought
more about it and I'm not as angry about
it
you mentioned the word also a law
earlier many people don't know that if
you're if you read the Arabic Christian
Bible if you're a Jew or a Christian and
you open up Genesis right there you have
almost I believe 17 times the word Allah
has mentioned Arabs and Jews who are
Arabic speaking they they use the word
Allah and Aramaic Allah ha Elohim you
know these are Semitic languages because
you know the linguish language didn't
exist so you know see when people
because they think you know the
propaganda law some moon god you know
something you know some pagan god but
this is this is just the Creator is
named in what we say in Arabic in German
gute in Spanish Dios right and English
God me I am Who am some pretty powerful
you know that's what a Muslim told me I
don't know if that's really what it
means but I heard Allah means I am okay
Allah the God the only one worthy of
worship
you can call Allah said you can call him
by any of his beautiful and all the
beautiful names to belong to a lot
ar-rahman ar-raheem the most gracious
the most merciful Allah do the loving
that just the compassionate you know so
these are he has 99 names mentioned in
the Quran and what we call the Sunnah so
any one of these names some have said
that Yahweh you know the everliving
right this would be one of his
attributes so by any one of these names
one can connect with with his creator
say the opening chapters of the Quran
start with in the name of God Almighty
Allah you translated the most gracious
the most merciful see ya but it's cool
it's all about gratitude yeah it's being
grateful and thankful you mentioned that
anything any who want that ben shapiro
hates that much there's got to be some
good there huh
that's another thing that sorry to get
me to like not you know rethink Muslims
is he's such a little just such a little
twerp just so too it a war crazy little
monster that uh whenever he really hates
something I have to think there's
something good there you know because
he's such a lying chicken hawk you know
he's trying to start all these wars that
he won't fight in that he can't even
justify and all he does is lie and
scheme and so when he would talk down
about Islam it made me think like well
there must be something to like about
these guys or else ben shapiro wouldn't
despise them you know mm-hmm when you
but you you uh when you when you go down
these different rabbit holes I just had
a doctor Kevin Barrett on the program
and we talked about one of these other
things that because Jill Rogan
he actually he brought it up with was
one of his guests they start talking
they started to talk about the what's
the reason you know these people hate us
so much and you know then he started to
talk about 9/11 like you know they're
over there they got nothing better to do
they're planning for some yeah just
sitting around you know and I mentioned
man these people are out there they're
like like you out there they got goats
and sheep they don't got TV and they're
minding their own business like they got
nothing better to do like they want to
just come over here and they just can't
wait to start and then then we started
to go deeper into building seven
architects and engineers I don't know if
you know about this do you have you gone
down that rabbit hole oh yeah it's like
these people just like what you're
describing I mean if I'm hanging out
with with a lot of these Muslims over
there we're talking goats we're talking
what's the best kind of go out of milk a
goat just how men talk yeah but like the
lie is that these people are like oh
they're so free over there I just hate
it so much and so then they get box
cutters from like staples they hijack a
Boeing 747 even though they can't fly a
prop plane they do something no pilot
can has ever been able to do and then
they drop buildings that can't drop by
this method and then building seven just
it's all such nonsense but the way
trauma-based mind control works you know
I'm fascinated by wizard rings my dad is
a rhetoric professor like how to
basically do a spell like mass
communications is a spell and so the
trauma of it was so big that it made
people almost give them a Stockholm
Syndrome and then the the media was
ready to go with bin Laden bin Laden bin
Laden bin Laden you know that name was
ready within 20 minutes just boom and so
the narrative had been painted and the
naivety of people to just believe what
they're told by authorities made them
rightfully so have a hatred for the
people who did it you know I'm from New
York State not New York City but people
knew firefighters that died people knew
people that got cancer like you saw
these buildings crumble and you felt you
know the part of me wanted to join them
bill extent and go you know against the
people who did it and looking back it's
so stupid it's such a rabbit trick it's
just so you know false flag doesn't even
begin to describe it and when people
like oh you question the 9/11 narrative
it's like how does anyone not question
that there's no pilot alive that thinks
that that was possible by these men you
couldn't hijack the planes that way none
of the black boxes survived but yet the
men's passports just fell down from the
sky and then a Good Samaritan picked it
up and lo and behold it's exactly who
the media thinks did it and it's like
we're such dukes and a lot of people
won't admit it because of the blood
that's been spilled in these unnecessary
and ridiculous wars but if you can't
admit you were tricked you'll be tricked
forever you know and it's like if you
can't admit that what are you gonna do
with your life you know if you can't
admit because some of these lies are so
big that people can't handle it you know
I used to be an agnostic I used to think
that uh I used to believe in evolution
and that we're all just from particles
and genitalia smashing together for
billions of years and when I realized
that wasn't true because it doesn't make
any logical sense anymore I didn't feel
shame you know somebody these pea
they don't want to admit they were wrong
and I think that comes from July you
know it's satanic it's like you don't
matter you are created by your trip it's
like when you when you find something
true you have to speak it and go with it
or else you're lost you know do you
think it becomes the bottom line now
becomes more it's more profits over
people it's more about just trending
fitting in because it's not cool now
it's not cool like what you're doing now
you know coming out speaking like this
now now it's not the coolest thing to do
because there's there's a quota there's
a you know like the sheep people are
just following and now now you going
against the grain you're going against
the odds why is that well it's a lack of
masculinity lack of masculinity yeah
it's a lack of men saying that's wrong I
like that it's like it goes God man
woman child and that isn't about
subjugation it's just it's just what it
is you know God guides and protects man
who serves God and and a man will
protect and guys why it could protection
guides the child and then the child in
some way reinvigorates God you know and
and so men have to be the ones that say
no that's wrong
it's like yeah but all the people are
gonna hit a thumbs down on the internet
it's like I am a man I'm not motivated
by that you know that's that's more of
how women are because it you know it the
the hunter versus together you know
women they're picking berries and
braiding hair and all that stuff it's
like when their community turns on them
they feel incredible beer and you know
they oh man I wish I could just play the
stand-up bit I did but about how men are
capitalist women are communists where
you know when when a woman is having a
bad time at a bar you know when there's
like a group of women out everyone is
having fun but one girl is having a bad
time it's like oh no Brian's here with
his new girl all the other girls are
like Tina's sad we all got to go home
wicker tears you know get on a unicorn
and matter like if a man's like I'm
really sad it's like get out of here you
know we're having a good time but the
opposite is true
where if a man is really fast and strong
or true or right it's like he's my
leader
that's my captain he's the fastest man I
love that guy and women are like she's
the prettiest tell everybody she has
herpes you know it's about bringing down
the high and raising up the low because
women are more into that that type of
living and men are the ones that have to
be the ones that say this is wrong you
know if you allow wise to propagate in
your community everyone dies you know if
you don't build strong fences that
weasel gets in and kills your chickens
if you don't uh you know admit what's
really happening your goats die your
wife dies your children die and so the
man has to be the one that takes those
arrows and bullets where people are like
oh it's not cool oh that's a pretty
popular it's like why would I care it's
not true and so without a strong man
that speaks truth the woman is cursed
that's why you see women taking on roles
of men you know they're in these
cubicles as wage slaves killing their
own children you know cursing men
because men have become women men are
just watching pornography and their moms
basements complaining that life isn't
easy enough for them and it's like men
need to have gratitude that's what I
love about Muslims is you guys have
gratitude towards the God you like that
the merciful the provider you know and
when a man does that they can actually
lead a woman and then the woman doesn't
have to be some weird hybrid of
male/female which is oddly like the
Satan you know this weird genderless you
know resentful goat
yeah and so it's like the masculine
energy has to it has to stay strong and
that's what I think is really missing is
is just these men who act like women and
you want approval and fancy clothes you
know lollipops and fancy pants and women
then we'll act like men until a man with
masculine energy comes in and provides
and protects and guides yeah that allows
her to be a mother to your child and if
that isn't honored if the man doesn't
honor God and if the woman doesn't out
of the man then you don't have a lineage
you are following people and we're
seeing
in places like Sweden and stuff like
that and people just want to complain
about Muslims and stop where it's like
all the Muslims it's like it's like oh
they burned down the church it's like
why why wasn't a man at the church
if I wasn't a man protecting the church
where were you home watching pornos and
they're like blue it's like no be a man
being masculine protect if you don't
have value in it God will take it right
back in the form of ashes you know what
do you what do you think we did some
programs after people were bringing to
our attention Joe Rogan in particular he
had he had talked about some things many
times with many guests he was bringing
on guests and they were they were making
some major blunders saying Islam as this
Islam is that it so I brought so I
brought on some academics people were
specially Imams she asks and then we
covered him all of these points they
brought up systematically academically
we didn't insult him we didn't you know
push hate towards him we just said hey
this is the truth and why don't you
bring on an academic bring on someone
like you did what you did said hey guys
and these trolls are out there and
you're like you know erase it you're not
gonna tell you know tell them slow down
hey I'll bring an imam on here man I'll
bring any mom and he'll answer the
question and if he's not truthful did I
I'll do a whole thing wrong I'll have a
Imam on here and we'll talk it out we'll
talk about I will have you guys email me
specific sections and we'll have someone
explain it and if we catch them lying
we'd never have to stir again you know
you said that why won't like Lauer
louder it was in a louder crowder or Joe
Rogan instead of talking about Muslims
bring a Muslim on and let's answer let's
talk let's dialogue because they're
magicians I mean they're they're lying
you know that's why when people say oh
are you Muslim now on because you're
friendly about my I'm like I'm confident
enough in my faith that I can talk I can
be friends with you because I think
you're honest I like you and it's like
if a Christian or a Satanist like Joe
Rogan is uncomfortable around a Muslim
and won't let a Muslim speak about their
faith it means there are liars and they
already know they're wrong
I think is a huge sin if you know you're
wrong and you want won't let someone
clear their name uh you're just a
horrible person and so I'm not scared of
the truth I'm not scared of of that and
some people are some people they say
they won't let anyone speak their side
because if they will they'll be crushed
and I think that's ridiculous
you know and if if I'm painting a
picture about somebody and I'm wrong I
would want that person be able to clear
it up and so a lot of people watched
when you when you talked about me on
your show and they were really touched
by it because a lot of Christians think
that Muslims just hate them you know and
so to see you um you know laugh about
one of my videos and talked about me
and not demonize me you got to
understand a lot of Christians think
that Muslims just despise them and hate
Jesus and all this stuff and it just
isn't true and without you know I'm
blessed to have a low level of beard
naturally I think but a lot of people
have too much beer to even explore these
ideas and understand that it's it's all
been a big lie you know and so I'm glad
that uh the people like you exist to
just say well let's just get on and
we'll talk about it you know yeah make
the human connection talk I mean that's
the start man but you know these things
are the people who don't want peace are
the people that that they don't profit
you know they don't profit from there
being peace so I know myself I try to
have peace with the Creator
I have that brings peace with myself and
I can go ahead and and and give that out
to others we say peace be with you you
know that's the greeting of Jesus we we
say peace be upon him the problem Ahamed
he said you know worship the most
merciful and spread peace you know so
when we say we're people of peace we
literally mean it and of course every
human being has a right to defend
themselves you know we're not you be a
man you know you you you guard your home
you guide your property you have a right
to defend yourself and your home and
your property what not in self-defense
but killing innocent human beings and
this whole thing that's been painted out
like Muslims are like the boogeyman and
they just have fangs ready
attack this is all nonsense and I'm glad
that someone like you is seen through
the media hype and and all the all the
nonsensical things that I said I commend
you god bless you and I really this is
popped my head profits over profits what
is it I that just came in my head that
could be a good slogan profits with a pH
over profits with a nap
yeah profits people worship on the dot
worshiping the money worshipping
materialism and forgetting about this
this this you know a human connection
that we just made hopefully we could be
a good example for others to follow
because I don't think I really I know I
mean when you have that hate inside
mentality
and you just end up stressed out you end
up I'm full of hate and and and you're
gonna end up getting sick from that that
actually make you sick and there's two
roads you know you somewhat i someone
pointed out i was like in one of my
streams i said i was crumbling upwards
no there's there's two roads it's a road
where you start stripping yourself of
your of your bad habits and your sins
and your hate you know because i had
some some family stuff this year that
really was just it made me have some
hate and uh and it helped it actually
helped me burn off the dead wood and
made me see you know you know like
praying for your enemy is really
important and i had that with with you
know people and someone in my family and
so that helped me actually see people
like muslims is not my enemy like an
honest muslim verse you know it's weird
how sometimes horrible things in your
life can help you get rid of the hate
and then let you smile and let you feel
grateful for being alive and in that
moment and yeah some you're always
welcome over here man man you can milk
goats
thank you brother i really appreciate it
I might take you up on that same thing
here if you're if you're in the in the
in the area let's let's stay in touch I
really enjoy talking to and most
important men do you know some of the
beautiful things that you've said and
and hopefully some people can can you
know been
from that more people can learn to you
know see past the the me I manipulation
and this is blind hate that they are
perpetuating exactly brother yeah so
peace be upon you so that would be with
you brothers please be with you
also Salam alaikum and that was Owen
Benjamin here on the Dean show Thank You
Owen was a pleasure having you on and
these talks are so important because as
he said you've been trained to think a
certain thing when we hear Muslims are
Islam is the boogeyman coming to get you
think about 9/11 never forget yeah I
never forget that Islam and Muslims had
nothing to do with 9/11 what is a Muslim
because when you know what Islam is and
when a Muslim supposed to be then you
can understand oh you're gonna question
twice as we do there's no way that a
Muslim can be doing such things yes I'm
Muslim drink alcohol they're not
supposed to some Muslims deal in usury
interests and I suppose to Islam says
one thing I'm Muslim I go ahead and do
the opposite just like some Christian
might do the opposite you don't judge a
car by the drunk driver so now when you
know what Islam is is to submit your
will to the Creator that have is an
earth and this is how you have peace in
life that's how you acquire peace and a
Muslim is one who does the action of
Islam by submitting your will to the
Creator to have as an earth and it's in
a lures player or father who are in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done that means I'm
gonna do what you want me to do
the one who created me has a right to
tell me what to do and how to be
successful in this life and the next so
now this is the main thing of Islam it
came to free the human being from
worshiping a stick stone a bone a human
being angels Saints know to worship just
the one God the creator of the heavens
and the earth and to free human beings
from the being enslaved to this material
world to the vast and from the
restrictive 'no sup this life to the
vastness of the next and you can't get
that by harming innocent human beings by
being a person of violence of terror no
way man so anytime someone throws
something at you
from the quran read it in context so
when you know what islam is you'll know
what islam is it and this is the same
way of life that was sent throughout
time that all the messengers of god
since the beginning the first man adam
no Moses Abraham Ishmael Isaac David
Jesus peace be upon them all and the
last and final messenger prophet
muhammad peace and Buzz's be appalled
they all came with Islam calling him
humanity to submit their will to the
creator of the heavens and earth and to
do good righteous deeds if you make a
mistake turn to the all loving the most
forgiving and repent you're gonna fall
short and it's not because of your good
deeds you get to paradise you because of
God's mercy but this is a manifestation
of your faith now you have some haters
paper of all Couture's they'll take the
penal code of Islam that's about 1% of
Islam to forget about to teach you about
the rest and they'll throw this out
there like Owen had mentioned the Fox
News and all these Bret Hart and the CNN
they'll throw certain things out there
to scare you but the majority of things
that are lies misinformation things and
if it's a half truth it's a lie so now
come to the Muslims come learn go ahead
let's have a dialogue ask sincerely if
you're in January you just own to throw
stones be careful you might be in a
glass house and now someone throws
something out there and we talked about
the Penal Code act as this acts as a
strong deterrent to keep the criminals
in check you have a police force
you have the army when things now need
to be taken to a next level to put these
people in check you have this of course
but look at reading in context look at
it from an academic standpoint has
someone explain it to you don't just
take it you know
Time magazine did an article exposing in
a span of 150 years that over 60,000
books were written against Islam so you
that was before Facebook and Twitter and
all this stuff and now if you're going
constantly you're gonna go ahead and
become what you read you're gonna go
ahead and revé all of this negative
propaganda go to a mosque sit with a
Muslim and a say hey look man what does
this mean when you talk about coffee it
what does it mean when hey chopping off
the hand what we don't know from this
thing but look at the context what we
said look at the content how it's
established when but know that anything
that God ordained there's wisdom in it
that it's for the mercy of humanity and
imagine if aliens came from outer space
and now they wanted to know just imagine
and they wanted to know about the u.s.
did the Constitution and then you just
show them the penal code the electric
chair lethal injection hanging what kind
of impression would they have and you
forgot about all
other beautiful things that are in the
Constitution that's the same thing now
quite that with Islam oh you've been
exposed to is some of the Penal Code
things out of context and now no no
wonder that you have this fear and
apprehension so make the connection go
ahead and continue to open your mind as
Owen did we respect that we have some
differences Islam we love we love for
Owen Benjamin and we love for the
viewers we love and this is out of out
of out of out of love that we'd love for
you to accept Islamic submission to the
will of the creator not the creation we
love that and this is not like you know
coming at it from a point like a we're
better at you putting down it's like
somebody who would love some good for
you who's inviting you to the house of
peace Dallas Lamas to house a piece we'd
love it but at the end if someone
chooses not to accept hey still it's
like someone who really wants to invite
you over you know to the to something
beautiful you respect that say look I I
can't accept an invitation but you'd
appreciate that that person reached out
for the invite so we give the invite but
if someone doesn't want to accept a
doesn't mean have to be hostile you have
people in your own home that you don't
agree with you have people in your own
home and your family that have different
views so we can go ahead and part on
these views and collaborate and other
good things that we agree upon but how
are we gonna make the world a better
place of peace that we acknowledge some
of these differences we respect each
other and we move on
but as Owen was talking about also who
doesn't want the peace the war machine
people who profit from their being war
so let's not be naive let's not fall for
these trips and traps thank you again
Owen Benjamin for being with us and
thank you all for tuning in to the D
show we'll see you next time tune in
every week for a new and exciting show
subscribe if you haven't already hit the
notification bell so you could be
updated and we started with peace and
the greeting of Jesus and all the
prophets peace be upon them and peace be
with you
a Salaam what a comb